Quick note before we get started, this episode includes a racial epithet and discussions about pornography. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Maps are good representations, not just of the world we live in, but of how we think about the world we live in. Over the centuries, our maps have emphasized the places we find important. They show the limits of our knowledge and the scope of our ambitions. 700 years ago, Europeans were completely unaware of the existence of North America. Fast forward to the 1970s. Scientists can tell you in detail what the surface of the moon is like.
在开始之前简单说明一下，本集包含种族污蔑词汇以及关于色情内容的讨论。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。地图是极好的表征，不仅能体现我们生活的世界，还能体现我们如何看待我们生活的世界。几个世纪以来，我们的地图一直重点标注我们认为重要的地点。它们展现了我们认知的局限以及雄心的范围。700年前，欧洲人完全不知道北美洲的存在。快进到20世纪70年代。科学家可以向你详细描述月球表面的样貌。
Today we're charting out maps of a different sort. Maps of our minds. Maps of our minds. Maps of our minds. There is in one cartographer designing these modern maps, we all are, and the maps are constantly changing. We start today's show with a personal question. Have you ever Googled something that you would never dream of saying out loud to another human being? When we have a question about something embarrassing or deeply personal, many of us today don't turn to a parent or
今天我们要绘制另一种地图。我们心灵的地图。我们心灵的地图。我们心灵的地图。没有哪个制图师在设计这些现代地图，我们所有人都在设计，而且这些地图在不断变化。我们以一个私人问题开启今天的节目。你有没有在谷歌上搜索过一些你做梦也绝不会对另一个大活人说出口的东西？当我们对某些令人尴尬或极其私密的问题感到好奇时，如今我们许多人求助的对象不是父母或
to a friend, but to our computers. Because there's just some things you just can't ask a real person in real life and you need to ask Google. Because it's completely anonymous and there are no judgments attached. Google knows everything. I agree to it.
朋友，而是我们的计算机。因为有些事情你就是在现实生活中无法问真人，而你必须去问谷歌。因为它是完全匿名的，而且不带任何评判色彩。谷歌无所不知。我同意这一点。
Every time we type into a search box, we reveal something about ourselves. As millions of us look for answers to questions or things to buy or places to meet friends, our searchers produce a map of our collective hopes, fears and desires. My guest today is Seth Stevens-Dividewitz. He used to be a data scientist at Google and he's the author of the book, Everybody Lies, Big Data, New Data, and what the internet can tell us about who we really are. Seth, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thanks so much for having me, Shankar. So Seth, we all know that Google handles billions of searches every day,
每当我们在搜索框中输入内容时，我们就会泄露一些关于我们自己的信息。当数以百万计的我们寻找问题的答案、要买的东西或与朋友聚会的地方时，我们的搜索行为汇成了一张反映我们集体希望、恐惧和欲望的地图。我今天的嘉宾是塞斯·斯蒂芬斯-达维多维茨。他曾是谷歌的数据科学家，也是《人人都在说谎：大数据、新数据以及互联网能告诉我们真实的自己》一书的作者。塞斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。噢，非常感谢邀请我来，尚卡尔。那么塞斯，我们都知道谷歌每天处理数十亿次的搜索，
but one of the insights you've had is that the reason Google knows a lot about us is not just because of the volume of search terms, but because people turn to Google as they might turn to a friend or a confidant. That's exactly right. I think there's something very comforting about that little white box that people feel very comfortable telling things that they may not tell anybody else about their sexual interests, their health problems, their insecurities, and using this anonymous aggregate data,
但你得出的见解之一是，谷歌之所以对我们了解甚多，不仅是因为搜索词的数量庞大，还因为人们求助谷歌的方式就像他们可能会向朋友或知己倾心吐露一样。完全正确。我认为那个小白框有一种非常舒缓的魔力，人们觉得向它倾诉那些可能不会对任何人说的事会感到非常自在，比如他们的性趣、健康问题、不安全感，并且通过这些匿名的汇总数据，
we can learn a lot more about people than we've really ever known. And one of the ways we can learn a lot more about people is through these very strange correlations, you find, for example, there's a relationship between the unemployment rate and the kinds of searches people make online. Yeah, I was looking at what searches correlate most
我们可以比以往任何时候都更加深入地了解人们。而我们能更深入了解人们的方式之一，就是通过这些非常奇怪的相关性，例如你发现失业率与人们在网上的搜索类型之间存在某种关联。是的，我当时在研究哪些搜索与失业率的相关性最高。
with the unemployment rate. And I was expecting something like new jobs or unemployment benefits. But during the time period, I looked at the single search that was most highly correlated with the unemployment rate with a pornography site. And you can imagine that if a lot of people are out of work, they have nothing to do during the day.
我本以为会是新工作或失业救济金之类的内容。但在我研究的那段时期，与失业率相关性最高的单一搜索竟然是一个色情网站。你可以想象，如果很多人失业了，他们白天就无所事事。
They may be more likely to look at porn sites. another search that was high on the list was solitary. So again, when people are out of work, they're bored, they do leisure activities, and potentially this measure of how much leisure there is on the internet may help us know how many people are out of work on a given day. And of course, this sort of helps us reconsider what we think of as data. So when we think about the unemployment rate, as you say, our normal approach is to say, how many people are selling jobs? Let's track down all the jobs. This is coming at the question entirely differently.
他们更有可能浏览色情网站。另一个在榜单上排名靠前的搜索是“独自一人”或“单人”。所以同样，当人们失业时，他们感到无聊，从事休闲活动，而这种对互联网上有多少闲暇时间的测量，可能有助于我们了解在特定的一天里有多少人失业。当然，这有助于我们重新审视我们对数据的理解。因此，当我们考虑失业率时，正如你所说，我们的常规方法是说，有多少人在出售工作？让我们追踪所有的工作。而这完全是从另一个角度来探讨这个问题。
Yeah, I think the traditional way to collect data was to send a survey out to people and have them answer questions, check boxes. There are lots of problems with this approach. Many people don't answer surveys, and many people lie to surveys. So the new era of data is kind of looking through all the clues that we leave. Many of them not as part of questions or as part of surveys, but just clues we leave as we go through our lives. One of the important differences between mining this kind of data and
是的，我认为收集数据的传统方式是向人们发送调查问卷，让他们回答问题、勾选方框。这种方法存在很多问题。许多人不回答调查，还有许多人在调查中撒谎。因此，新时代的数据有点像是通过我们留下的所有线索来进行观察。其中许多线索并非作为问题或调查的一部分，而只是我们在生活中前行时留下的蛛丝马迹。开采这类数据与
the responses we get on surveys has to do with how people report their sexual orientation. I understand that the kind of queries that you see on Google might reveal something quite different than if you ask people if they're gay. That's right. If you ask people in surveys today in the United States about two and a half or three percent of men say that they're primarily attracted to men. And this number is far higher in certain states where tolerance to homosexuality is greater. So there are a lot more gay men according to surveys in California than in Mississippi. But if you look at search data for gay male pornography, it's a tiny bit higher in California, but not that much higher,
我们在调查中得到的反馈之间的一个重要区别，与人们如何报告其性取向有关。据我了解，你在谷歌上看到的查询类型，可能与你直接问人们是否是同性恋时揭示的情况截然不同。确实如此。如果你今天在美国的调查中问人们，大约百分之二点五或百分之三的男性会说他们主要被男性吸引。在对同性恋包容度更高的某些州，这个数字要高得多。因此，根据调查，加利福尼亚州的男同性恋人数远多于密西西比州。但如果你查看男同性恋色情内容的搜索数据，加利福尼亚州只高出一小点，并没有高出那么多，
and overall about 5% of male pornography search is for gay porn, so almost twice as high as the numbers you get in service. Your research has important implications for a topic that we've looked at a lot on Hidden Brain, the topic of implicit bias. People aren't always aware of the biases they hold, and so scientists have had to find clever ways to unearth these biases. You think that Google searchers can reveal some forms of implicit bias? That's right. So one I look at is the questions that parents have about their children. If you ask many parents today, they would say that they treat their sons and daughters equally. That they're equally excited about their intellectual potential,
而且总体而言，在男性色情搜索中，大约有5%是关于同性恋色情内容的，几乎是调查中得出数字的两倍。你的研究对我们在《隐藏的大脑》中经常探讨的一个主题——隐性偏见主题，有着重要的启示。人们并不总是意识到自己持有的偏见，因此科学家不得不寻找巧妙的方法来挖掘这些偏见。你认为谷歌搜索者可以揭示某些形式的隐性偏见吗？确实如此。我研究的其中一点是父母对孩子提出的问题。如果你今天问许多父母，他们会说他们平等对待儿子和女儿。他们对孩子的智力潜能感到同等兴奋，
equally concerned about maybe their weight problems. But if you aggregate everybody's Google searches, you see large differences in gender that when parents in the United States ask questions starting, is my son, there might much more likely to use words such as gifted or a genius than they would in a search starting is my daughter. When parents in the United States search is my daughter, they're much more likely to complete it with is my daughter overweight or is my daughter ugly. So parents are much more excited about the intellectual potential of their sons and much more concerned about the physical appearance of their daughters. Before I get to the next question, Seth, I just want to give a warning to our listeners. This next section is going to involve a discussion regarding the N-word.
对孩子的体重问题可能也同样关心。但如果你将所有人的谷歌搜索聚合起来，你会发现性别之间存在巨大差异：当美国的父母提出以“我的儿子是否”开头的提问时，他们更有可能使用诸如“有天赋的”或“天才”之类的词，而如果搜索是以“我的女儿是否”开头，他们就不会这样做。当美国的父母搜索“我的女儿是否”时，他们更有可能用“我的女儿超重吗”或“我的女儿长得丑吗”来完成搜索。因此，父母对儿子的智力潜能更加兴奋，而对女儿的外表则更加担忧。在我提出下一个问题之前，塞斯，我只想给我们的听众一个警告。接下来的这部分将涉及对N开头的种族蔑称（N-word）的讨论。
Seth, you report that in some states after Barack Obama was first selected president, there were more Google searches for a certain racist term than searches for first black president. I think there is a disturbing element to some of this search data where in the United States, today, many people, and maybe this is a good thing, don't feel comfortable sharing that they have racist thoughts or racist feelings, but on Google, they do make these searches in strikingly high frequency. I need to use sorted language to this. The measure is the percent of Google searches that include the word, and these searches are predominantly
塞斯，据你报道，在巴拉克·奥巴马首次当选总统后的一些州，对某个种族主义术语的谷歌搜索量，竟然超过了对“第一位黑人总统”的搜索量。我认为其中某些搜索数据带有一种令人不安的成分：在今天的美国，许多人——也许这是一件好事——觉得公开自己有种族主义思想或种族主义情绪是不合适的，但在谷歌上，他们确实以惊人的高频率进行了这些搜索。我需要为此使用经过筛选的语言。这个指标是包含该词的谷歌搜索所占的百分比，而这些搜索绝大多数是
searches looking for jokes, mocking African Americans. I should clarify, this is not searches for rap lyrics, which tend to use the word, the ending in A. But if you look at the racist search volumes, I think if you had asked me based on everything I had read about racism in the United States, I would have thought that racism in the United States predominantly concentrated in the South, that really the big divide in the United States when it comes to racism is South versus North. But the Google data reveals that's not really the case that racism is actually very, very high in many places in the North,
寻找笑话、嘲笑非裔美国人的搜索。我应该澄清一下，这并不是指那些倾向于使用以字母a结尾的该词的饶舌歌词搜索。但是如果你看看种族主义搜索量，我想如果你根据我所读过的关于美国种族主义的一切来问我，我本会认为美国的种族主义主要集中在南部，认为美国在种族主义方面真正的大分水岭是南部对北部。但谷歌数据表明并非如此，事实上，许多北方地方的种族主义非常非常高，
places like Western Pennsylvania or Eastern Ohio or industrial Michigan or rural Illinois or upstate New York. The real divide these days when it comes to racism is not North versus South, it's East versus West. There's much higher racism, East of the Mississippi than West of the Mississippi. So besides just saying, you know, we know that there are these patterns of racist searches in different parts of the country, you're actually saying you can do more than that. You can actually predict how different parts of the country might vote in a presidential
比如西宾夕法尼亚州、东俄亥俄州、工业密歇根州、乡村伊利诺伊州或纽约州北部。如今在种族主义方面真正的分水岭不是北方对南方，而是东方对西方。密西西比河以东的种族主义程度远高于密西西比河以西。所以，除了说“你知道，我们知道国家不同地区存在这些种族主义搜索的模式”之外，你实际上是说你可以做得更多。你实际上可以根据你在国家不同地区看到的谷歌搜索类型，来预测国家不同地区在总统
election based on the kind of Google searches you see in different parts of the country. Yeah, well, the first thing I found is that there was a large correlation between racist search volume and parts of the country where Obama did worse than other democratic candidates had done. So, Barack Obama was the first major party general election nominee who was African-American, and you see a clear relationship that Obama lost large numbers of votes in parts of the country where there are high racist search volumes and other researchers have found such as Nate Silver at 538 and Nate Cohn at the New York Times that there was
选举中会如何投票。是的，嗯，我发现的第一件事是，种族主义搜索量与奥巴马表现比其他民主党候选人更差的地区之间存在很大关联。所以，巴拉克·奥巴马是第一位获得非裔美国人身份的主要政党大选提名人，你可以看到一个明显的联系：在种族主义搜索量很高的地区，奥巴马失去了大量的选票，其他研究人员也发现了这一点，比如来自538网站（538）的内特·西尔弗（Nate Silver）和《纽约时报》的内特·科恩（Nate Cohn），他们发现
a large correlation between racist search volumes and support for Donald Trump and the Republican Party that parts of the country that made racist searches in high numbers were much more likely to support Donald Trump. And this relationship was much stronger than really any other variable that they tested. I'm wondering how you try and understand that kind of information. It's hard not to listen to what you're saying and draw sort of what seems to be a superficial conclusion, which is that racist people vote for Donald Trump. I'm not sure is that what you're saying? That's one of those things where it sounds so offensive to say it that I think everyone
种族主义搜索量与对唐纳德·特朗普及共和党人的支持之间存在很大关联：那些产生大量种族主义搜索的地区更有可能支持唐纳德·特朗普。这种关系比他们测试过的任何其他变量都要强得多。我想知道你是如何尝试理解这种信息的。听着你的话，很难不去得出一个似乎很肤浅的结论，那就是种族主义者投票给了唐纳德·特朗普。我不确定这真的是你的意思吗？这就是那种说出来听着太冒犯以至于我认为每个人都在
tiptoes around the line. I will say that the data does show a strong correlation between racist searches and support for Donald Trump that is hard to explain with any other explanation. You know, it's, yeah, I mean, yeah, that kind of is what I'm saying. I'm not saying that everybody who supported Donald Trump is racist by any stretch of imagination. There are plenty of people who support Donald Trump without this racist tendency, but a significant fraction of his supporters, I think, were motivated by racial animus. Seth Stevens-Devita Witch is a former Google data scientist
如履薄冰的话题。我要说的是，数据确实显示了种族主义搜索与对唐纳德·特朗普的支持之间存在强烈的相关性，这是用任何其他解释都很难说得通的。你知道，是的，我的意思是，是的，这在某种程度上就是我的意思。我并不是说每一个支持唐纳德·特朗普的人都是种族主义者。有很多人在支持唐纳德·特朗普时并没有这种种族主义倾向，但我认为他的一相当一部分支持者是受到种族敌意的驱使。塞斯·斯蒂芬斯-达维多维茨是一位前谷歌数据科学家，
and the author of Everybody Lies, big data, new data, and what the internet can tell us about who we really are. You spend a lot of time in the book talking about sex. It turns out to be an area where marketers and companies know that what we say about ourselves is nowhere close to the truth. Most people report being not interested in pornography, but the website PornHub reports that in 2015 alone,
也是《人人都在说谎：大数据、新数据以及互联网能告诉我们真实的自己》一书的作者。你在书中花了很多时间讨论性。事实证明，这是一个营销人员和公司深知我们对自己的说辞与真相相去甚远的领域。大多数人报告说对色情内容不感兴趣，但PornHub网站报告称，仅在2015年，
viewers watched two and a half billion hours of porn, which is apparently longer than the entire amount of time that humans have been on Earth. What is the say about us, the fact that we either have very little insight about ourselves or we're actually lying through our teeth. Yeah, I'd say we're probably lying through our teeth.
观众就观看色情内容达到了二十五亿小时，这显然比人类在地球上存在过的整个时间还要长。这说明了什么关于我们的事实：是我们对自己的了解非常少，还是我们实际上在满口谎言？是的，我想说我们可能在满口谎言。
I do talk a lot about sex in this book. One thing I like to say is that big data is so powerful it turned me into a sex expert because it wasn't a natural area of expertise for me. But I do talk a lot about sexuality and I think you do learn a lot about people that's very, very different from what they say, and kind of the weirdness at the heart of the human psyche that doesn't really reveal itself in everyday life or at lunch tables, but does reveal itself at 2am on PornHub. Pornography sites are on the only ones gathering information about our sexual and romantic
我在这本书里确实谈了很多关于性的内容。我喜欢说的一点是，大数据威力如此巨大，以至于把我变成了一个性专家，因为这对我来说并非一个天生的专业领域。但我确实谈了很多关于性欲的事情，我认为你确实能了解到很多关于人们的、与他们口头所说截然不同的一面，以及人类心灵深处的那种怪异之处——它不会真正在日常生活中或餐桌上显现出来，但确实会在凌晨两点时分在PornHub上暴露无遗。色情网站并不是唯一一个收集我们性与浪漫
preferences. We now have apps like Tinder and sites like OkCupid that gather tons of data about us. As a result, these apps and sites know a lot about our romantic preferences. But for a long time, we've had a human version of big data for romance. Grandma. Set has some personal experience with this Big Data source. A couple of years ago, he was having Thanksgiving dinner with his family.
偏好信息的平台。我们现在有了像Tinder这样的应用和像OkCupid这样的网站，它们收集了大量关于我们的数据。因此，这些应用和网站对我们的浪漫偏好了解颇深。但长期以来，我们一直拥有一个人类版本的浪漫大数据。奶奶。
He was 33, didn't have a date with him, and his family was trying to figure out the qualities set needed in a romantic partner. My family was going back and forth. My sister was saying that I need a crazy girl, because I'm crazy. My brother was saying that my sister was crazy, that I need a normal girl to balance me out and my mom was screaming at my brother and sister that I'm not crazy and my dad was then screaming at my mom that of course
塞斯对这个大数据源有一些亲身经历。几年前，他正和家人一起吃感恩节晚餐。他33岁，没有带伴侣出席，他的家人正试图弄清楚塞斯在浪漫伴侣身上需要具备哪些特质。我的家人争论不休。我姐姐说我需要一个疯狂的女孩，因为我很疯狂。我哥哥说我姐姐才疯狂，我需要一个正常的女孩来平衡我，我妈妈对我哥哥和姐姐大喊大叫说我不疯狂，然后我爸爸对我妈妈大喊大叫说塞斯
Seth is crazy. So it's kind of a classic Steven's Davidoid family Thanksgiving where everyone's just yelling at each other for being crazy and we're not really getting any progress in learning about yelling at each other for being crazy and not really getting any progress in learning about what I need in my love life. And then my soft spoken 88-year-old grandma started to speak and everyone went quiet and she explained to me that I need a nice girl, not too pretty, very smart, good with people, social so you will do things, sense of humor because you have a good sense of humor. And I describe why I was her advice so much better than everybody else's. I think one of the reasons that she's big data, right? So, grandmas and grandpas throughout history
当然很疯狂。所以这算是一场经典的斯蒂芬斯-达维多维茨家族感恩节聚会，每个人都在对别人大喊大叫，指责对方疯狂，而我们在了解我爱情生活中到底需要什么这件事情上并没有取得任何进展。然后，我那位说话温和的88岁奶奶开始说话了，所有人都安静了下来。她向我解释说，我需要一个好女孩，不要太漂亮，非常聪明，擅长与人相处，懂得社交以便你会一起做事情，还要有幽默感，因为你很有幽默感。我描述了为什么我那么喜欢她的建议，而胜过其他所有人的建议。我想原因之一在于她就是大数据，对不对？所以，历史上的爷爷奶奶们
have had access to more data points than anybody else and they've been able to correlate larger patterns than anybody else has because they've been around longer. And that's why they've been such an important source of wisdom historically. The problem, of course, as you also point out, is that it's very hard to disentangle your personal experiences from what actually happens in the world. And in your grandmother's case, she actually had a very specific piece of relationship advice about the kind of person you should want. And some of that might not actually be backed up by the empirical
接触过的数据点比任何人都多，他们能够比任何人都更好地关联出更大范围的模式，因为他们活得更久。这就是为什么他们在历史上一直是智慧的重要来源。当然，正如你所指出的那样，问题在于很难将你的个人经历与世界上实际发生的事情解耦。在你奶奶的例子中，她其实关于你应该想要什么样的人，给出了一个非常具体的恋爱建议。而其中一些建议实际上可能并没有得到实证
evidence. Yeah, well, my grandma told me, has told me on multiple occasions that it's important to have a common set of friends and a partner. So she lived in a small apartment in Queens, New York with my grandfather and every evening they'd go outside and gossip with their neighbors. And she thought that was a big part in why their relationship worked. But actually recently, computer scientists have analyzed data from Facebook, and they can actually look when people are in relationships and when they're out of relationships, and
证据的支持。是的，嗯，我奶奶告诉我，曾多次告诉我，和伴侣拥有一套共同的朋友很重要。因此，她和我爷爷住在纽约皇后区的一间小公寓里，每天晚上他们都会出去和邻居八卦。她认为这是他们的感情能够维系的重要原因。但事实上，最近计算机科学家分析了来自Facebook的数据，他们实际上可以观察人们何时处于恋爱关系中以及何时结束恋爱关系，并
try to predict what factors or relationship make it more likely to last. One of the things they tested was having a common group of friends. Some partners on Facebook share pretty much the same friend group and some people have totally isolated friend groups. And they found, contrary to my grandmother's advice that having a separate social circle is actually a positive predictor of a relationship lasting. And so of course, the risk of trusting the individual
尝试预测恋爱的哪些因素更有可能使其持久。他们测试的事情之一就是拥有共同的朋友群。Facebook上的一些伴侣共享差不多的朋友圈，而有些人的朋友圈则完全孤立。他们发现，与我奶奶的建议相反，拥有一个独立的社交圈实际上是恋爱关系持久的一个积极预测因素。因此，当然，信任个人的
is that the individual's intuition about what work for his or her life might not work for everyone else. That's right. I think we tend to get biased by our own situation. Data scientists have a phrase called waiting data. Some data points get extra weight in our models, and our intuition gives too much weight to our own experience, and we tend to assume that what worked for us
风险在于，个人对他或她的生活如何运作的直觉可能并不适用于其他人。确实如此。我认为我们往往会被自己的处境所左右。数据科学家有一个短语叫赋权数据或加权数据。一些数据点在我们的模型中获得了额外的权重，而我们的直觉赋予了我们自己的经验过多的权重，我们往往会假设对我们管用的方法
will work for others as well, and that's frequently not the case. Many companies know that we don't really understand ourselves. When we come back, we look at how companies are using big data to predict what we're going to do before we know it ourselves. We'll also ask if sites like Google can use data to forecast whether you're going to get a serious illness, should they give you that information? Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're speaking today with former Google Data Scientist, Seth Stevens-Devidovets, about the research in his book, Everybody Lies, Big Data, New Data, and what the internet can tell us about who we really are. Netflix used to ask users what kind of movies
对别人也同样管用，而事实往往并非如此。许多公司都知道我们其实并不真正了解自己。稍后回来，我们将探讨公司如何利用大数据在我们自己察觉之前预测我们的行为。我们还将探讨像谷歌这样的网站是否可以利用数据来预测你是否会患上重病，它们是否应该将此信息告诉你？请留给我们。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们与前谷歌数据科学家塞斯·斯蒂芬斯-达维多维茨一起探讨他书中的研究，书名是《Everybody Lies, Big Data, New Data, and what the internet can tell us about who we really are》（人人都在说谎：大数据、新数据以及互联网能告诉我们真实的自己）。网飞（Netflix）过去常常询问用户想看什么类型的
they wanted to watch. Sets says eventually the company realized that asking this kind of question was a complete waste of time. Yeah, initially Netflix would ask people what they want to view in the future so they could queue up the movies that they said and if you ask people what they want to view in the future so they could queue up the Movies that they said and if you ask people what are you gonna want to watch tomorrow or this weekend People are very aspirational. They want to watch documentaries or about world war two or avant-garde French films But then when Saturday or Sunday comes around they want to watch the same low-brow comedies that they've always watched.
电影。塞斯说，这家公司最终意识到，问这种问题完全是浪费时间。是的，起初网飞会问人们未来想看什么，以便他们可以把你说的电影排入队列，如果你问人们明天或这个周末你想看什么，人们往往抱有很高的志向。他们想看纪录片，或者关于二战的纪录片，或者是前卫的法国电影。但当周六或周日到来时，他们只想看他们一直以来爱看的那些低俗喜剧。
So as Netflix realized, they had to just ignore what people told them and use their algorithms to figure out what they actually want to watch. So one of the things that's intriguing about what you just said is it's, I don't think it's actually the case that people were lying to Netflix when they said they wanted to watch the Aman Guard film. They actually genuinely probably aspired to do that. It might actually be that big data understands people better that they understand themselves. Yeah, probably even more common than lying to other people is lying to ourselves, particularly when we're trying to predict what we're going to do in two or three days.
因此，正如网飞所意识到的那样，他们必须忽略人们告诉他们的话，转而利用算法来弄清楚他们实际上想看什么。所以你刚才所说的话中引人入胜的一点是，我不认为人们对网飞说他们想看前卫电影时是在撒谎。他们当时可能确实真心抱有这种志向。实际情况可能确实是大数据比人类更了解人类。是的，比对别人撒谎更常见的，可能还是对自己撒谎，特别是当我们试图预测两三天后自己会做什么的时候。
We tend to assume that we're going to go to the gym more than we go to the gym or eat better than we actually will eat or watch more intellectual stuff than we actually will watch so that algorithms can correct for this over optimism that we all tend to share. When you look at a company like Facebook, which has access to these huge amounts of data about us and what we like and whom we like in our relationships. You have to wonder how the company is using this data in all kinds of different ways.
我们往往会假设自己去健身房的次数会比实际去得多，或者吃得比实际吃得更好，或者看比实际更有内涵的内容，因此算法可以纠正这种我们所有人往往都有的过度乐观情绪。当你看到像Facebook这样拥有海量关于我们、我们的喜好以及我们在恋爱关系中喜欢谁的数据的公司时，你不得不思考这家公司是如何以各种不同方式利用这些数据的。
I remember Facebook got into some hot water a couple of years ago because they ran an experiment that seemed to be manipulating how people feel. Of course, there was a huge outcry about the experiment at the time. Since then, there hasn't been very much reported about what Facebook is doing, but I suspect that it might just be because Facebook is no longer telling us what it's doing, but it's still doing it anyway. Every major tech company now runs lots and lots of what are called A, B tests, which are little experiments where you put people into two different groups,
我记得Facebook几年前曾陷入一些麻烦，因为他们做了一个实验，似乎在操纵人们的情绪。当然，当时对这个实验的抗议声铺天盖地。从那以后，关于Facebook在做什么的报道并不多，但我怀疑这可能仅仅是因为Facebook不再告诉我们它在做什么，但它其实依然在照做不误。现在每一家大型科技公司都在运行大量所谓的A/B测试，也就是小型的实验，你把人们分成两组，
a treatment and control group, and you show one group, one version of your site, and the other group, another version of the site, and you see which version gets the most clicks or the most views. This is really exploded in the tech industry. There are many, many instances where companies are now using big data against us. Banks and other financial institutions are using clues from big data to decide who shouldn't get a loan. I think it's an area of a big concern, so I talk about a study in the book where they started to peer to peer lending a site and they started to text the people used in their requests for loans and you can figure out just from what people say in their loans
实验组和控制组，你向一组展示你网站的一个版本，向另一组展示网站的另一个版本，然后看哪个版本获得最多的点击量或浏览量。这在科技行业确实呈爆炸式增长。现在有很多很多实例表明，公司正在利用大数据来对付我们。银行和其他金融机构正在利用大数据的线索来决定谁不该获得贷款。我认为这是一个令人高度担忧的领域，所以我谈到了书中的一项研究，他们开始使用点对点借贷网站，并开始分析人们在贷款申请中使用的文本，你可以仅从人们在贷款时说的话中
How likely they are to pay back and there are some strange correlations for example if you mention the word God Your 2.2 times less likely to pay back 2.2 times more likely to default and this does get eerie Are you really supposed to be penalized if you mentioned God in a loan application that would seem to be really wrong, even evil, to penalize somebody for a religious preference. Basically, everything's correlated with everything, right? So just about anything anybody does is going to have some predictive power for other things they do. And the legal system is really not set up for a world in which companies potentially can
看出他们偿还贷款的可能性有多大，并且存在一些奇怪的相关性，例如，如果你提到“上帝”这个词，你偿还贷款的可能性就会降低2.2倍，违约的可能性会增加2.2倍。这确实让人感到毛骨悚然，难道你在贷款申请中提到上帝真的应该受到惩罚吗？这似乎大错特错，甚至有点邪恶，因为某人的宗教偏好而惩罚他。基本上，万物皆相关，对吧？因此，人们做的几乎任何事情都对他们做的其他事情具有一定的预测能力。而法律体系根本没有为一个这样的世界做好准备：在这个世界里，公司有可能
mine correlations over just about everything anybody does in their life. I was thinking about an ethical issue. I'm not sure if necessarily this is a legal issue, but you mentioned in the book that, you know, if someone is googling, I've been diagnosed with pancreatic cancer, what should I do? It's reasonable to assume that this person has been diagnosed with pancreatic cancer, what should I do? It's reasonable to assume that this person has been diagnosed with pancreatic cancer. But if you collect all the people who are googling what to do about that diagnosis with pancreatic cancer
挖掘出关于人们生活中所做的一切事物的相关性。我一直在思考一个伦理问题。我不确定这是否必然是一个法律问题，但你在书中提到，如果有人在谷歌搜索“我被诊断出患有胰腺癌，我该怎么办？”，可以合理地假设这个人已经被诊断出患有胰腺癌，我该怎么办？可以合理地假设这个人已经被诊断出患有胰腺癌。但如果你收集所有那些在谷歌搜索如何应对该胰腺癌诊断的人，
and then work backwards to see what they've been searching for in the weeks and months prior to that diagnosis, you can discover some pretty amazing things. Yeah, this is a study that researchers use Microsoft Bing data. They looked at people who searched for just Yeah, this is a study that researchers use Microsoft Bing data. They looked at people who searched for just diagnoses of pancreatic cancer and then similar
然后进行逆向追踪，看看他们在确诊前几周和几个月里一直在搜索什么，你就能发现一些相当惊人的事情。是的，这是一项研究，研究人员使用了微软必应（Bing）的数据。他们观察了那些仅仅搜索了
people who never made such a search. Then they looked at all the health symptoms they had made in the lead up to either a diagnosis or no diagnosis. They found that there were very, very clear patterns of symptoms that were far more likely to suggest a future diagnosis of pancreatic cancer. For example, they found that searching for indigestion and then abdominal pain was evidence of pancreatic cancer while searching for just indigestion without abdominal pain meant to person was much more unlikely to have pancreatic cancer.
胰腺癌诊断的人，以及从未进行过此类搜索的类似人群。然后他们查看了这些人在确诊或未确诊之前所出现的所有健康症状。他们发现，存在非常非常清晰的症状模式，这些模式更有可能预示着未来会被诊断出患有胰腺癌。例如，他们发现搜索消化不良然后是腹痛是患有胰腺癌的证据，而仅仅搜索消化不良却没有腹痛则意味着此人患胰腺癌的可能性要小得多。
That's a really, really subtle pattern in symptoms, right? Like a time series of one symptom, followed by another symptom is a evidence of a potential disease. It really shows, I think, the power of this data where you can really tease out very subtle patterns in symptoms and figure out which ones are potentially threatening and which ones are benign. So here's the ethical question. Once you establish that there is this correlation that you sort of say I have a universe of people
这是一种非常非常微妙的症状模式，对吧？就像一个症状的时间序列，接着是另一个症状，就是潜在疾病的证据。我认为这确实展示了这种数据的强大威力，你可以真正理清症状中非常微妙的模式，并弄清楚哪些可能具有威胁性，哪些是良性的。所以这里的伦理问题是：一旦你确立了存在这种相关性，即你可以说我有一群人，
who clearly have pancreatic cancer, and I work backwards through their search history and I detect these patterns that no one had thought to look at before that say these particular kinds of search terms seem to be correlated with people who go on to have the diagnosis versus these search terms that do not go on to predict a diagnosis. So does a company like Microsoft now have an obligation to tell people who are googling for these combinations of search terms?
他们明显患有胰腺癌，然后我通过他们的搜索历史进行逆向追踪，并检测出这些以前没有人想到过去寻找的模式，这些模式表明这些特定类型的搜索词似乎与最终确诊的人相关，而另一些搜索词则不能预测确诊。那么像微软这样的公司现在是否有义务告诉那些在谷歌搜索这些搜索词组合的人：
Look, you might actually need to get checked out. You might actually need to go see a doctor because of course, if you can be diagnosed with pancreatic cancer four weeks earlier, you have a much better chance of survival than if you have to wait for a month. I lean in the direction of yes, some people would not lean that direction. It could be a little creepy. If Google, right below the button, I feel lucky. You may have pancreatic cancer.
“看，你可能真的需要去检查一下。你可能真的需要去看医生”，因为当然，如果你能提前四周被诊断出患有胰腺癌，你的生存几率要比等上一个月大得多。我倾向于“是”这一方向，有些人则不会倾向于那个方向。这可能会有点让人毛骨悚然。如果谷歌在“我手气不错”按钮的下方显示：你可能患有胰腺癌。
It's not exactly the most friendly thing to see on a website. But personally, if I had some sort of symptom pattern that suggested I may have a disease and there was a chance of curing it if I was told, I'd want to know that. It's just another example that really the ethical and legal framework that we've set up is not necessarily prepared for big data. Seth Stevens-Devitawitz is a former data scientist at Google and the author of the book, Everybody Lies, Big Data, New Data, and what the internet can tell us about who we really are. Seth, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
这绝对不是在网站上看到的最友好的事情。但就我个人而言，如果我有一些症状模式表明我可能患有某种疾病，并且如果被告知还有治愈的可能，我会想知道这一点。这只是另一个例子，真正表明我们建立的伦理和法律框架不一定为大数据做好了准备。塞斯·斯蒂芬斯-达维多维茨是一位前谷歌数据科学家，也是《人人都在说谎：大数据, 新数据以及互联网能告诉我们真实的自己》一书的作者。塞斯，感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
Thanks so much for having me, Shankar. Have you ever talked to your computer, cursed it for making a mistake? PC load letter? Does that mean? Have you ever argued with the traffic directions you get from Google Maps or Ways? Starting route to Grover's Mill Road. Have you ever looked at a Roomba cleaning the floor on the other side of the room and told it, please come over to this side.
非常感谢邀请我来，尚卡尔。你有没有对你的计算机说过话，因为它犯错而诅咒它？PC装载信件（PC load letter）？那是什么意思？你有没有跟谷歌地图或Waze提供的交通路线争辩过？正在规划前往格罗弗斯米尔路的路线。你有没有看着Roomba在房间另一头的地板上清扫，然后对它说，请到这边来。
Turn left. Left! It just ran its sound right off of the edge. Robots and artificial intelligence are playing an ever-large role in all of our lives. Of course, this is not the role that science fiction once imagined. It doesn't feel pity or remorse or fear. Robots bent on our destruction, remain the stuff of movies like Terminator, and robot sentience is still an idea that's far off in the future.
向左转。左边！它直接从边缘冲下去了。机器人和人工智能在我们的所有生活中扮演着越来越大的角色。当然，这并不是科幻小说曾经想象的角色。它感受不到怜悯、懊悔或恐惧。一心想要毁灭我们的机器人仍然是《终结者》这类电影的题材，而机器人的感知能力仍然是一个遥远未来的概念。
But there's a lot we're learning about smart machines, and there's a lot that smart machines are teaching us about how we connect with the world around us and with each other. My guest today has spent a lot of time thinking about how we interact with smart machines and how those interactions might change the way we relate to one another. Kate Darling is a research specialist at the MIT Media Lab. She joined us recently in front of a live audience at the hotel Jerome in Aspen, Colorado, as part of the Aspen Ideas Festival. Also on stage was a robot.
但关于智能机器，我们正在学到很多东西，智能机器也在教给我们很多关于我们如何与周围世界以及彼此建立联系的知识。我今天的嘉宾花了很多时间思考我们如何与智能机器互动，以及这些互动可能会如何改变我们彼此关联的方式。凯特·达尔ิง（Kate Darling）是麻省理工学院媒体实验室的研究专家。她最近作为阿斯彭创意节的一部分，在科罗拉多州阿斯彭的杰罗姆酒店的现场观众面前加入了我们。舞台上还有一个机器人。
A green robot dinosaur about the size of a small dog known as a play-o. It's going to be part of this conversation, but before we get to that, here's Kate. Kate, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. You found that there is an interesting point in the relationship between humans and machines, and that point comes when we give a machine a name. I understand that you have three of these play or dinosaurs at your home.
一个绿色的小狗大小的机器人恐龙，被称为PLEO。它将成为这次对话的一部分，但在我们切入正题之前，有请凯特。凯特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我。你发现人类与机器人的关系中有一个有趣的转折点，这个转折点出现在我们给机器人起名字的时候。据我了解，你家里有三只这种PLEO恐龙。
Can you tell me some of the names that you have given to your robots? Yes. So the very first one I bought, I named Yohai after Yohai Benchler, who's a Harvard professor, who's done some work in intellectual property and other areas that I've always admired. And the second one I adopted after I filmed a Canadian documentary where the show host had to name the robot
你能告诉我一些你给你的机器人起的名字吗？可以。我买的第一个，我给它起名叫约哈伊，取自约哈伊·本克勒（Yohai Benkler），他是一位哈佛教授，在知识产权和我一直钦佩的其他领域做过一些工作。我领养第二个是在我拍摄了一部加拿大纪录片之后，节目主持人必须给机器人起个名字，
and he gave the robot the same name he had, which was Peter. So the second one has a boring name. And then the third one is named Mr. Spaghetti. I don't know if people outside of Boston are familiar with this, but the Boston Public Transportation System, they wanted to crowdsource a name for their mascot dog. And the internet decided that the dog should be named Mr. Spaghetti. And of course, they refused to do that and named the dog Hunter.
他给机器人起了他自己的名字，也就是彼得。所以第二个名字很无聊。然后第三个叫“意大利面条先生”（Mr. Spaghetti）。我不知道波士顿以外的人是否熟悉这个，但波士顿公共交通系统想要为他们的吉祥物狗众包一个名字。而互联网决定这只狗应该叫“意大利面条先生”。当然，他们拒绝这样做，并把这只狗命名为亨特。
So Mr. Spaghetti became a big thing in Boston for a while. People were very outraged about this. And so I named my PLEO, my third one, Mr. Spaghetti. I understand that companies actually have found that if you sell a robot with the name of the robot on the box, it changes the way people will interact with that robot, then if you just said, this is a dinosaur. So, this is, yeah, this is not, I don't have any data on this, but yes, I have talked to companies who feel that it helps with adoption and trust of the technology. Even very, very simple robots, like boxes on wheels that deliver medicine in hospitals.
所以“意大利面条先生”在波士顿火了一阵子。人们对此非常愤怒。于是我给我的PLEO，我的第三个，起名叫“意大利面条先生”。据我了解，公司实际上发现，如果你在盒子上标上机器人的名字来出售机器人，与你只是说“这是一只恐龙”相比，它会改变人们与该机器人互动的方式。所以，这，是的，这并非，我没有这方面的具体数据，但是的，我和一些公司交谈过，他们觉得这有助于产品的普及和人们对技术的信任。即使是非常非常简单的机器人，比如在医院里运送药品的轮式箱子。
If you give them a little nameplate that says Betsy, their understanding is that people are a little bit more forgiving of the robot. So instead of this stupid machine doesn't work, they'll say, oh, Betsy made a mistake. And I'm wondering if you've spent time thinking about why this happens. At some level, if I came up to you at home
如果你给它们挂上一块写着“贝茨”（Betsy）的小铭牌，他们的理解是人们对机器人的包容度会稍微高一点。所以人们不会说“这个蠢机器不工作”，而是会说“哦，贝茨犯了个错误”。我想知道你是否花时间思考过为什么会这样。在某种程度上，如果我在家里走到你面前，
and I said, Kate, is Mr. Spaghetti alive? You would almost certainly tell me, no, Mr. Spaghetti is not alive. I assume tell me no, Mr. Spaghetti is not alive. I assume you don't think Mr. Spaghetti is alive, right? No. Okay. So given that you know that Mr. Spaghetti is not alive, why do you think giving him a name changes your relationship to him? With robots in particular it's combined with just our general tendency to anthropomorphize these things and we're also primed by science fiction and pop culture to give robots names and view them as entities
然后我对你说，“凯特，意大利面条先生还活着吗？”，你几乎肯定会告诉我“不，意大利面条先生没有活着”。我猜你会告诉我“不，意大利面条先生没有活着”。我假设你并不认为意大利面条先生还活着，对吧？没有。好的。既然你知道意大利面条先生没有活着，为什么你认为给他起个名字会改变你与他的关系？对于机器人而言，这尤其结合了我们赋予这些事物拟人化的普遍倾向，而且我们也被科幻小说和流行文化所潜移默化，从而给机器人起名字并将它们视为具有
with personalities. And it's more than just the name, right? I mean, robots move around in a way that seems autonomous to us. We respond to that type of physical movement. Our brains will project intent onto it. So I think robots are in the perfect mixture of something that we will very willingly treat with human qualities
个性的实体。这不仅仅是一个名字，对吧？我的意思是，机器人的移动方式对我们来说似乎是自主的。我们会对这种身体运动做出反应。我们的大脑会将意图投射到它身上。所以我认为机器人完美融合了某种我们会非常乐意用人类特质
or lifelike qualities. All right, so we have this wonderful little prop in front of us. It's a play or dinosaur. I want you to tell me a little bit about the play or dinosaur, how it works, and how you come to one three of them, Kate. What is or dinosaur. I want you to tell me a little bit about the play or dinosaur, how it works, and how you come to one three of them, Kate. What is the dinosaur?
或类人特质去对待的特性。好了，所以我们面前有一个非常棒的小道具。它是一只PLEO恐龙。我想让你跟我多讲讲这只PLEO恐龙，它是如何工作的，以及你是如何拥有其中三只的，凯特。什么是恐龙？
What does it do? It's basically an expensive toy. I bought the first one, I think, in 2007. There we go, it's awake. They have a lot of motors and touch sensors, and they have an infrared camera and microphones. So they're pretty cool pieces of technology for a toy, and that's initially why I bought one because I was fascinated by everything that it can do. Like, if it starts walking around, it can walk to the edge of the table.
它是做什么的？它基本上是一个昂贵的玩具。我想我是在2007年买的第一只。好了，它醒了。它们有很多马达和触觉传感器，它们还有红外摄像头和麦克风。所以作为玩具来说，它们是非常酷的技术产品，这也是我最初买一个的原因，因为我被它能做的一切深深吸引了。比如，如果它开始走动，它能走到桌子边缘。
It can look down, measure the distance to the floor. It knows that there's a drop, and it'll get scared and walk backwards. And then they go through different life phases adolescent and fully grown and it'll have moods. So I think what we should do, we bought the robot at Hidden Brain a couple of weeks ago. We haven't had the chance to give it a name yet. And I thought we should actually reserve the honors for this evening, where we're talking to Kate,
它能往下看，测量到地面的距离。它知道那里有个落差，它会感到害怕并往后退。然后它们会经历不同的生命阶段——青春期和完全长成——并且会有情绪。所以我想我们应该这么做，我们在几周前为《隐藏的大脑》买了这个机器人。我们还没来得及给它起名字。我想我们应该把这个荣誉留给今天晚上，我们在和凯特交谈的时候。
and see if Kate wants to try and name this dinosaur. Oh, you know, since she cares about dinosaurs so much. I was looking up Kate's Twitter feed this morning. I understand that you're going to have a baby soon. Congratulations. Yes, I don't have a name for that either. OK. Just FYI, she sometimes refers to the baby as baby bot, so just for whatever that's worth.
看看凯特愿不愿意试着给这只恐龙起个名字。哦，你知道的，既然她这么关心恐龙。我今天早上看了看凯特在Twitter上的发帖。我听说你们很快就要有宝宝了。恭喜。是的，我也还没给它想好名字。好吧。顺便说一下，她有时会把这个宝宝叫作“宝宝机器人”，所以大家就当是这么回事吧。
And one retweet that you have on your Twitter feed cracked me up, it said, you don't really know how many people you don't like until you start trying to pick baby names. Yeah, that's a vote for my husband. So I don't want to tell me, you apparently haven't yet picked your baby's name. So do you have any choices of top choices? Is there a name, a spare name that you might care to give the dinosaur? Well the problem is we've had a girl's name picked out for years and now we're having a boy and we just can't, we don't even have any contenders.
你在Twitter上转发的一条推文把我逗乐了，上面写着：“直到你开始尝试给宝宝起名字时，你才真正知道有多少人是你讨厌的。”是的，这是为我丈夫投的一票。所以你不想告诉我，显然你还没选好你宝宝的名字。那你有什么首选的选择吗？有没有一个备用名字，你愿意给这只恐龙用？嗯，问题是，我们多年前就挑好了一个女孩的名字，现在我们要生个男孩，我们就是想不出来，甚至连一个候选的名字都没有。
No contenders. What would have been your favorite girl's name if you had had a girl? Well, so when I first started dating my now husband, he at some point said, if I ever had a daughter, I already know what I would name her. And I was like, oh, really? We're going to fight about this one. And he said, yeah, I would name her Samantha and Sam
没有候选名字。如果你生的是女孩，你最喜欢的女孩名字是什么？嗯，当我刚开始和我现在的丈夫约会时，他有一次说，如果我生个女儿，我已经知道我要给她起什么名字了。我说，哦，真的吗？我们要为这件事吵一架了。他说，是的，我会给她起名叫萨曼莎（Samantha），简称为
for short, because Sam is kind of gender neutral. And I was like, oh, I Really love that. So that one was was picked out very easily. All right, since you're not having a girl They're gonna have a boy would you mind if if you considered naming the dinosaur Samantha? How would you feel about that? Oh, that would be awesome. We should name the dinosaur Samantha. All, so henceforth, this dinosaur will be called Samantha or Santa Shore. Yay! Now, some time ago, Kid conducted a very interesting experiment with the play of dinosaurs, and to sort of show how this works, I have a second prop here, which is under the table. Uh-oh.
萨姆（Sam），因为萨姆有点性别中立。我说，哦，我真的很喜欢那个名字！所以那个名字很容易就定下来了。好吧，既然你们生的不是女孩，而是要生个男孩，你介不介意，如果你考虑把这只恐龙命名为萨曼莎？你对此有什么感觉？哦，那太棒了！我们应该把这只恐龙命名为萨曼莎。好的，那么从今以后，这只恐龙就叫萨曼莎，或者叫“萨塔肖尔”（Santa Shore）。太棒了！不久前，凯特对恐龙玩具做了一个非常有趣的实验，为了展示这是怎么运作的，我这里有第二个道具，就在桌子底下。哦，不。
Uh-oh. It's a hammer. I have a second prop here, which is under the table. It's a hammer. A large hammer, which we borrowed from the hotel. Now, as you all know, the dinosaur is obviously not alive. It's just cloth and plastic and a battery and wires. It has a name, of course, Samantha. But it isn't alive in any sense of the term. And so Kate, I'm going to actually give you the hammer.
哦，不。是一把锤子。我这里有第二个道具，在桌子底下。是一把锤子。一把从酒店借来的大锤子。正如大家所知，这只恐龙显然不是活的。它只是一堆布、塑料、电池和电线。当然，它有个名字叫萨曼莎。但它在任何意义上都不是活的。所以，凯特，我要把这把锤子交给你。
Oh, no. And I think we might have a little board underneath the table here. We're going to place the dinosaur on a board. Kate, would you consider destroying Samantha? No. It's just a machine. I only make other people do that. I don't do it myself.
哦，不。我想桌子底下可能有一块小木板。我们要把恐龙放在木板上。凯特，你考虑过毁掉萨曼莎吗？不。它只是一台机器。我只让别人做这种事。我自己可不做。
You wouldn't even consider harming the dinosaur? Well, so my problem is that I already know the results of our research and that would say something about me as a person, so I'm going going to say no I'm not willing to do it. Kate Darling is a research specialist at the MIT Media Lab. When we come back I last heard about that research he references in which he asked volunteers to smash a robot dinosaur. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We're discussing our relationships with technology, specifically robots, with Kate Darling, a researcher from MIT.
你甚至连伤害这只恐龙都不考虑吗？嗯，我的问题是，我已经知道我们研究的结果了，那会反映出我作为一个人的某些特质，所以我要说不，我不愿意这么做。凯特·达林（Kate Darling）是麻省理工学院媒体实验室（MIT Media Lab）的研究专家。当我们回来时，我最后听到的是她提到的那项研究，她在研究中要求志愿者砸碎一只机械恐龙。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。我们正在与来自麻省理工学院的研究人员凯特·达林一起探讨我们与技术的关系，特别是与机器人的关系。
She joined us before a live audience at the Aspen Ideas Festival. A couple of years ago, Kate conducted an experiment that says a lot about how humans tend to respond to certain kinds of robots. Tell me about the experiment. So you had volunteers come up and you basically introduced them to these lovable dinosaurs, and then you gave them a hammer like this and you told them to do what. Well, so, okay, so this was the workshop part that we used the dinosaurs for. They're a little too expensive to do an experiment with 100 participants.
她在阿斯彭思想节（Aspen Ideas Festival）上加入我们，面对现场观众进行了交流。几年前，凯特做了一个实验，这个实验很大程度上说明了人类对某些类型的机器人做出反应的倾向。跟我讲讲这个实验吧。所以你让志愿者走过来，基本上把这些可爱的恐龙介绍给他们，然后你给了他们这样一把锤子，你让他们做什么。嗯，所以，好吧，这是我们使用恐龙的工作坊部分。用100名参与者来做实验有点太昂贵了。
So the workshop that we did in a non-scientific setting, we had five of these robot dinosaurs. We gave them the groups of people and had them name them, interact with them, play with them. We had them personify them a little bit by doing a little fashion show with a fashion contest. And then after about an hour, we asked them to torture and kill them. And we had a variety of instruments. We had a hammer, a hatchet, and I forget what else. But even though we tried to make it dramatic, it turned out to be a little bit more dramatic
所以我们在非科学环境中举办的工作坊里，有五只这样的机械恐龙。我们把它们分给不同的人群，让他们给它们起名字、与它们互动、和它们玩耍。我们通过举办一个小型的时装秀和时尚比赛，让他们对它们进行了一点拟人化。然后在大约一个小时后，我们要求他们折磨并杀死它们。我们有各种各样的工具。我们有一把锤子、一把手斧，我还忘了别的什么。但尽管我们试图让它变得戏剧化，结果却比
than we expected it to be, and they really refused to even hit the things. And so we had to kind of start playing mind games with them, and we said, okay, you can save your group's dinosaur if you hit another group's dinosaur with a hammer. And they tried, and they couldn't do that either. This one woman was standing over the thing trying, and she just couldn't, she ended up petting it instead. And then finally we said okay well we're gonna destroy all of the robots unless someone takes a hatch it to one of them. And finally someone did. Wait so you said unless one of you kills one of them we are gonna kill all of them? Yeah I think this might have
我们预期的还要戏剧化得多，他们真的拒绝去打这些东西。所以我们不得不开始对他们玩心理战，我们说，好吧，如果你用锤子打了另一个组的恐龙，你就可以拯救你那组的恐龙。他们试过了，也做不到。有个女人站在那东西旁边尝试，但她就是做不到，最后她反而去抚摸它了。然后我们最后说，好吧，除非有人用手斧砍死其中一个机器人，否则我们要把所有的机器人全毁了。最后有人真的这么做了。等等，你是说除非你们其中一人杀死其中一只，否则我们要把它们全杀了？是的，我想这可能
been my partner's idea. So I did this with a friend named Honest Gossel. We did this at a conference called Lift and Geneva. And we had to improvise because people really didn't want to do it. So we threatened them. And I think that clearly doesn't want you to harm her. Yeah, clearly, clearly. So what do you think is going on?
是我搭档的主意。我和一个叫奥内斯特·戈塞尔（Honest Gossel）的朋友一起做的。我们在日内瓦举行的名为“Lift”的会议上做了这个。我们不得不即兴发挥，因为人们真的不想这么做。所以我们威胁了他们。我想那显然不想让你伤害她。是的，很明显，很明显。所以你认为发生了什么？
I mean, at a rational level, the dinosaur obviously is not alive. Why do you think we have such reluctance to harming the dinosaur? In fact, I might have the battery removed so the dinosaur stops making noise. OK. Well, I mean, it behaves in a really life-like way.
我的意思是，在理性的层面上，这只恐龙显然不是活的。你认为为什么我们对伤害恐龙如此抗拒？事实上，我可能会把电池取下来，这样恐龙就不发出声音了。好吧。我的意思是，它的行为方式真的很像活物。
I mean, we have over a century of animation expertise in creating compelling characters that are very life like that people will automatically project life onto you. I mean, look at Pixar movies, for example. It's incredible. And I know that a lot of social robotists actually work with animators to create these compelling characters. And so, you know, it's very hard to not see this as some sort of living entity, even though,
我的意思是，我们在创造引人注目的角色方面拥有一百多年的动画专业知识，这些角色非常逼真，人们会自动将生命投射到它们身上。我的意思是，看看皮克斯（Pixar）的电影，例如。这太不可思议了。而且我知道很多社交机器人专家实际上与动画师合作来创造这些引人注目的角色。所以，你知道，很难不把这看作某种有生命的实体，尽管
you know, perfectly well, that it's just a machine because it's moving in this way that we automatically subconsciously associate with states of mind. And so I just think it's really uncomfortable to people, particularly for robots like this that can display, you know, a simulation of pain or discomfort to have to watch that. I mean, it's just not comfortable. What did you find in terms of who was willing to do it and who wasn't? I mean, when you looked at the people who are willing
你心知肚明这只是一台机器，因为它的移动方式是我们自动下意识地与心理状态联系在一起的。所以我只是认为这让人们很不舒服，特别是对于像这样能够表现出痛苦或不适模拟的机器人来说，不得不观看那一幕。我的意思是，这真的让人不舒服。从谁愿意这样做、谁不愿意这样做的角度，你发现了什么？我的意思是，当你观察那些愿意
to destroy a dinosaur, a dinosaur like the Clio, you found that there were certain characteristics that were attached to people who were more or less likely to do the deed. So the follow-up study that we did, not with the dinosaurs, we did with hex bugs, which are a very simple toy that moves around like an insect. And there we were looking at people's hesitation to hit the hex bug and whether they would hesitate more if we gave it a name, and whether they would hesitate more if they had natural tendencies for empathy, for empathic concern.
毁掉恐龙（像克利奥那样的恐龙）的人时，你发现某些特征与更有可能或更不可能做这件事的人联系在一起。所以我们做的后续研究，不是用恐龙，而是用微型爬虫机器人（hex bugs），这是一种非常简单的玩具，像昆虫一样四处移动。在那里，我们观察人们对击打微型爬虫机器人的犹豫程度，以及如果我们给它起个名字他们是否会更犹豫，以及如果他们天生具有同理心、同理心关怀的倾向，他们是否会更犹豫。
And we found that people with low empathic concern for other people, they didn't much care about the hex bug and would hit it much more quickly. And people with high empathic concern would hesitate more and some even refuse to hit text bugs. So in many ways what you're saying is that potentially the way we relate to these inanimate objects might actually say something about us at a deeper level than just our relationship to the machine.
我们发现，对他人缺乏同理心关怀的人，他们不太在乎微型爬虫机器人，会更快地打它。而具有高度同理心关怀的人会更加犹豫，有些人甚至拒绝击打微型爬虫机器人。所以在很多方面，你所说的意思是，我们在潜意识里与这些无生命物体建立联系的方式，实际上可能比我们与机器的关系更深层地说明了我们的一些特质。
Yes, possibly. I mean, we know now or we have some indication that we can measure people's empathy using robots, which is pretty interesting. You know, my colleagues and I were discussing ahead of this interview, whether you would actually destroy the dinosaur. And we were torn because we said on the one hand, you of all people should know that these are just machines, and that it's an irrational belief to project life-like values on them. But on the other hand, I said, you know, it's really unlikely she's going to do it because she's going to look like a really bad person if she smashes the dinosaur in front of 200 people.
是的，有可能。我的意思是，我们现在知道了，或者有一些迹象表明，我们可以通过机器人来衡量人们的同理心，这相当有趣。你知道，我的同事和我在这次采访前一直在讨论，你是否真的会毁掉这只恐龙。我们很纠结，因为一方面我们说，你最应该知道这些只是机器，把类似生命的价值投射到它们身上是一种不理智的信念；但另一方面，我说，你知道，她真的这样做的可能性很小，因为如果她在200人面前砸碎这只恐龙，她看起来会像个非常糟糕的人。
I mean, I don't know if you've been watching Westworld at all, but the people who don't hesitate to shoot the robots they seem pretty callous to us. It's, and I think maybe there is something to it. Of course, we can rationalize it. Of course, if I had to, I could take the hammer and smash the robot, and I wouldn't have nightmares about it. But I think that perhaps turning off that basic instinct to hesitate to do that might be more harmful than Overr, you know, I think overriding it might be more harmful than just going with it.
我的意思是，我不知道你有没有看过《西部世界》（Westworld），但那些毫不犹豫地向机器人开枪的人在我们看来相当冷酷。这，而且我想这其中也许真有什么道理。当然，我们可以为此找理由。当然，如果必须的话，我可以拿起锤子砸碎机器人，我也不会因此做噩梦。但我认为，也许关闭那种犹豫不决的基本本能可能会比……超越它，你知道的，我认为压制它可能会比顺其自然更有害。
I want to talk about the most important line we draw between machines and humans and it's not intelligence But it's consciousness. I want to play your little clip from Star Trek. Now tell me, come on, that what is data? I don't understand. What is he? A machine? Is he, are you sure? Yes.
我想谈谈我们在机器和人类之间划下的最重要的界限，它不是智能，而是意识。我想播放你的一小段《星际迷航》（Star Trek）剪辑。现在告诉我，拜托，什么是“Data”？我不明白。他是什么？一台机器？他是，你确定吗？是的。
You see, he's met two of your three criteria for sentience, so what if we meet the third? Consciousness, and even the smallest degree? What is he then? I don't know. You? Do you? So this has been a perennial concern in science fiction,
你看，他满足了你对有感知力的三个标准中的两个，那如果我们满足了第三个呢？意识，哪怕是最小程度的？那他是什么？我不知道。你呢？你知道吗？所以这是科幻小说中一个常青的关注点，
which is the idea that at some point, machines will become conscious and sentient. And very often, it's in the context of, the machines will rise up and harm the humans and destroy us. But as I read your research, I actually found myself thinking, is our desire to believe that the machines can become conscious, actually just an extension of what we've been talking about the last 20 minutes, which is we project sentience onto machines all the time.
也就是在某个时刻，机器将变得有意识和有感知力。而且往往是在这样的语境下：机器将崛起并伤害人类，摧毁我们。但当我阅读你的研究时，我发现自己在想：我们渴望相信机器能够变得有意识，其实真的只是我们过去20分钟一直在讨论的内容的延伸吗？也就是说，我们一直在把感知力投射到机器身上。
And so when we imagine what they're going to be like in the future, the first thing that pops in our head is, they're going to become conscious. Yeah, I think there's a lot of projection happening there. I also think that before we get to the question of robot rights and consciousness, we have to ask ourselves, how do robots fit into our lives when we perceive them as conscious, because I think that's when it starts to get morally messy and not when they actually inherently have some sort of consciousness. If humans have a tendency to anthropomorphize machines to see them as human. It isn't surprising that
所以当我们想象它们未来会是什么样子时，我们脑海中浮现的第一件事就是：它们将变得有意识。是的，我认为那里发生了很多投射。我也认为，在我们探讨机器人权利和意识的问题之前，当我们把机器人视为有意识的时，我们必须问自己：机器人是如何融入我们的生活的？因为我认为正是从那时起，事情开始变得在道德上陷入泥潭，而不是当它们本身真正具备某种意识时。如果人类有将机器拟人化、将它们视为人的倾向，那么
we're also willing to bring all the biases we have toward our fellow human beings into the machine world. Many of the intelligent assistants being built by major companies, Siri or Alexa are being given women's names. Many of the genius machines are often given men's names, how or what's in. Now, you can say, Siri and Alexa aren't people. Why should we care? Why should we care if people sexually harass their virtual assistants, as has been shown to sometimes happen?
我们也愿意把对同类人类的所有偏见带入机器世界，这也就不足为奇了。大公司制造的许多智能助手（如Siri或Alexa）都被赋予了女性名字。许多天才机器人都经常被赋予男性的名字，如何，或者有什么讲究。现在，你可以说，Siri和Alexa又不是人。我们为什么要在乎？为什么要在乎人们是否对他们的虚拟助手进行性骚扰，就像有时被爆出来的那样？
MIT's Kate Darling says, we should care, because the way we treat robots may have implications for the way we treat other human beings. It might. We don't know, but it might. And one example with the virtual assistance you just mentioned is children. So parents have started observing, and this is anecdotal,
麻省理工学院的凯特·达林说，我们在乎是因为我们对待机器人的方式可能会对我们对待其他人类的方式产生影响。可能会。我们不知道，但可能会。你刚才提到的虚拟助手的一个例子就是儿童。所以父母们开始观察到——这是轶事，
but they've started observing that their kids adopt behavioral patterns based on how they're interacting with these devices and how they're conversing with them. And there are some cool stories. Like there was story in the New York Times a few years ago where a mother was talking about how her autistic son had developed a relationship with Siri, the voice assistant. And she said, this was awesome because Siri is very patient.
但他们开始观察到，他们的孩子根据他们与这些设备的互动方式以及他们与这些设备的对话方式，采用了行为模式。有一些很酷的故事。比如几年前《纽约时报》上有一个故事，讲的是一位母亲谈到她的自闭症儿子是如何与语音助手Siri建立关系的。她说，这太棒了，因为Siri非常有耐心。
She will answer questions repeatedly and consistently. And apparently this is really important for autistic kids. But also because her voice recognition is so bad, he learned to articulate his words really clearly and it improved his communication with others. Now, that's great, but these things aren't designed with autistic kids in mind, right? That's kind of more of a coincidence than anything.
她会一遍又一遍、始终如一地回答问题。显然这对自闭症儿童非常重要。而且由于她的语音识别功能太差了，他学会了非常清晰地咬字发音，这改善了他与他人的沟通。现在，这很棒，但这些东西在设计时并没有把自闭症儿童放在心上，对吧？这与其说是有意为之，不如说是个巧合。
And so there are also perhaps some unintended effects that are more negative. And so one guy wrote a blog post, a well-backed where he said, Amazon's echo is magical, but it's turning my child into an echo because Alexa doesn't require please or thank you or any of the standard politeness that you want your kids to learn when they're conversing and when they're demanding things of you.
所以可能也有一些更具负面影响的意料之外的效果。于是有个家伙写了一篇博客文章，背景很好，他说，亚马逊的Echo很神奇，但它正在把我的孩子变成一个Echo，因为Alexa不需要“请”或“谢谢”，也不需要你希望你的孩子在与你对话以及向你索取东西时学到的任何标准礼貌。
So it starts there, but I think that as this technology improves and gets better at mimicking real conversations or life-like behavior, you have to wonder to what extent that gets muddled in our subconscious, and not just in children's subconscious, but maybe even in our own. Do you think it's a coincidence that most of the virtual assistants are given female names and female identities?
所以它是从那里开始的，但我认为随着这项技术的改进，在模仿真实对话或类人行为方面变得更好，你不得不怀疑这在多大程度上混淆了我们的潜意识，不仅是孩子们的潜意识，甚至可能是我们自己的潜意识。你认为大多数虚拟助手被赋予女性名字和女性身份是个巧合吗？
I think it's a combination of whatever market research, but also just people not thinking. I mean, I visited IBM Watson in Austin, and there's a room that you can go into and you can talk to Watson and he has this deep booming male voice and you can ask questions. And at the time I went there, there was a second AI in the room that turned on the lights and greeted the visitors and that one had a female voice. And I pointed that out, and it seemed like they hadn't really considered that. So it's a mixture of people thinking, oh, this is going to
我认为这是任何市场研究的结合，但也只是人们没有动脑筋。我的意思是，我参观了奥斯汀的IBM沃森（IBM Watson），有一个房间你可以进去和沃森对话，他有着低沉洪亮的男声，你可以问问题。当时我去的时候，房间里还有第二个AI，它会开灯并向访客打招呼，那个AI有着女声。我指出了这一点，他们似乎并没有真正考虑过这一点。所以这是一群人想着“哦，这样会卖得更好”，和另一群人根本没动脑筋的结合，因为构建这项技术的团队主要是年轻的、白人男性。他们有这些盲点，甚至没有考虑通过这些系统的设计，他们可能会延续什么样的偏见。
sell better, and people just not thinking at all, because the teams that are building this technology are predominantly young, white, and male. And they have these blind spots where they don't even consider what biases they might perpetuate through the design of these systems. So you sometimes call a robot ethicist, and you've sometimes said we might need to establish
所以你有时被称为机器人伦理学家，你也曾说过我们可能需要为机器人建立
a limited legal status for robots. What do you mean by that? So yeah, it's a little bit of a provocation, but my sense is that if we have evidence that behaving violently towards very life-like objects not only tells us something about you as a person but can also change people and desensitize them to that behavior in other contexts, so if you're used to kicking a robot dog, are you more likely to kick a real dog, then that might actually be an argument if that's
有限的法律地位。你是什么意思？所以，是的，这有点像是一种挑衅，但我的感觉是，如果我们有证据表明，对非常逼真的物体表现出暴力行为不仅能向我们揭示你作为一个人的某些特质，还能改变人们并让他们对其他语境下的这种行为变得麻木——如果你习惯了踢机械狗，你是否更有可能踢真正的狗？——那么，如果情况确实如此，这实际上可能是一个理由，赋予机器人某些法律保护，就像我们给予动物保护一样，但原因不同。我们喜欢对自己说，我们为动物提供免受虐待的保护，是因为它们确实经历了疼痛和苦难。其实我并不认为这是我们这样做的唯一原因，但对于机器人来说，这个想法不是它们体验到了什么，而是这让我们变得麻木。对机器人实施虐待
the case to give robots certain legal protections the same way that we give animals protections, but for a different reason. We like to tell ourselves that we give animals protection from abuse because they actually experience pain and suffering. I actually don't think that's the only reason we do it, but for robots, the idea would be not that they experience anything, but rather that it's desensitizing to us. And it has a negative effect on our behavior
会对我们的行为产生负面影响。所以这里有一件值得思考一会儿的事情。如果你听说，例如，某人在他们的农场里养了一群鸡，对吧？所以那是他们的农场，他们的鸡，鸡是他们的。他们真的在虐待这些鸡，看着他们伤害这些鸡。
to be abusive towards the robots. So here's a thing that sort of it's worth sort of pondering for a moment. If you hear, for example, that someone owns a bunch of chickens in their farm, right? So it's their farm, their chickens, they own the chickens. And they're really mistreating the chickens to watching them harming them.
你可以提出一种产权的论点，说他们可以对自己的财产做任何他们想做的事。但我认为我们中的许多人会说，即使鸡属于你，有些关于鸡的事你是可以做的，有些是不能做的。而且我不确定这仅仅是因为我们担心如果你虐待这只鸡，那就意味着你会变成那种可能虐待其他人的人，
You could sort of make a property rights argument and say they can do whatever they want with their property. But I think many of us would say, even though the chicken belongs to you, there are certain things you can and cannot do with the chicken. And I'm not sure it's just about our concern that if you mistreat the chicken, that means you will turn into the kind of person who might mistreat other people,
这里有一种层面，我认为在某种道德层面上，虐待动物的想法对我们来说是具有冒犯性的。我在想，机器是否也是如此，也就是说，不仅仅是伤害机器的人也可能愿意伤害人类这种情况，仅仅是伤害那些看起来、感觉起来和听起来有感知力的东西这种行为，在某种程度上就是道德上具有冒犯性的。
there is sort of a level, there's a certain moral level at which I think the idea of abusing animals is offensive to us. And I'm wondering what the same thing is true with machines as well, which is it's not just the case that it might be that people who harm machines are also willing to harm humans, but just the act of harming things that look and feel and sound sentient is morally offensive in some way.
是的，所以我认为这绝对是我们处理大多数动物保护问题的方式，因为这也是……很明显，我们对某些动物的关心多于其他动物，而且这不是基于任何生物学标准。所以我认为，例如，我们只是觉得虐待猫在道德上具有冒犯性，或者，你知道，在美国，我们不喜欢吃马肉的想法，但在欧洲，他们会觉得，马和牛有什么区别？它们都很美味。
Yeah, so I think that's absolutely how we've approached most animal protections, because it's also... it's very clear that we care more about certain animals than others and not based on any biological criteria. So I think that we just find it morally offensive, for example, to torture cats or, you know, in the United States, we don't like the idea of eating horses, but in Europe, they're like, what's the difference between a horse and a cow? They're both delicious.
所以这绝对是我们倾向于运作的方式，也是我们倾向于通过这些法律的方式。我不明白为什么一旦机器达到更先进的水平，我们真正把它们视为栩栩如生，并且看到它们被虐待对我们来说真的很冒犯时，这同样不能适用于机器。这一论点的魔鬼代言人的一面，当然是人们会不会说，按下开关关掉机器，这是不道德的，因为你本质上是在杀死机器人？
So that's definitely how we tend to operate and how we tend to pass these laws. And I don't see why that couldn't also apply to machines once they get to a more advanced level where we really do perceive them as lifelike and it is really offensive to us to see them be abused. The devil's advocate side of that argument, of course, is that would people then say pressing a switch and turning off a machine, that's unethical because you're essentially killing the robot?
但我们并不保护动物不被杀死。我们只是保护它们免受不必要的残酷对待。所以我其实认为动物虐待法在这里是一个很好的对照。你刚才提到了《西部世界》，我想为您播放一段《西部世界》的剪辑，对于那些没看过《西部世界》的人来说，人类与机器人互动，这些机器人极其逼真，逼真到有时很难分辨你是在和一个机器人说话还是在和一个人类说话。在我将要播放的片段中，一个叫威廉的男人和一个可能是也可能不是机器人的女人互动。你想问，那就问吧，威廉和一个可能是也可能不是机器人的女人互动。你想问。那就问吧。
But we don't protect animals from being killed. We just protect them from being treated unnecessarily cruelly. So I actually think animal abuse laws are a pretty good parallel here. You mentioned Westworld some moments ago, and want to play you a clip from Westworld for those of you who haven't seen Westworld Humans interact with robots in a robots that are extremely lifelike so lifelike that it's sometimes difficult to tell whether you're talking to a robot or you're talking to a human In the scene that I'm about to play you a man named William interacts with a woman who may or may not be a robot You want to ask, so ask and William interacts with a woman who may or may not be a robot. You want to ask. So ask.
你是真的吗？嗯，如果你分辨不出来，这重要吗？所以当我观看这个片段并阅读你的作品时，我确实有了一个想法，我想把这个开始实验的想法运行在你身上，也就是，你知道，在光谱的一端，我们有这些日益变得栩栩如生、像人的机器，你知道，它们以非常智能的方式做出反应，看起来就像它们是活的；而在另一端，我们正在了解关于人类的各种事情，这些事情向我们表明，即使是我们心灵中最复杂的方面也是由一套规则和规律支配的，
Are you real? Well, if you can't tell, does it matter? So as I watched the scene and as I read your work, I actually had a thought and I want to sort of run the start experiment by you, which is that, you know, on one end of the spectrum, we have these machines that are increasingly becoming lifelike, human-like, you know, they respond in very intelligent ways, they seem as if they're alive. And on the other hand, we're learning all kinds of things about human beings that show us that even the most complex aspects of our minds are governed by a set of rules and laws,
在某些方面，我们的心灵运作也是由一套规则和规律支配的，在某些方面，我们的心灵运作有点像机器。我在想，真的有那么巨大的区别吗？这是可能的吗？真正的问题与其说是机器能变得更像人类，不如说其实有没有可能人类实际上只是一种高度进化的机器？我毫不怀疑我们是高度进化的机器。我不认为我们已经理解了我们是如何运作的，我也不认为我们很快就能达到那种理解，但是的，我认为我确实
and in some ways, our minds function governed by a set of rules and laws, and in some ways our minds function a little bit like machines. And I'm wondering, is there really a huge distinction? Is it possible, is the real question not so much can machines become more human-like, but is it actually possible that humans are actually just highly evolved machines? I have no doubt that we are highly evolved machines. I don't think we understand how we work yet, and I don't think we're going to get to that understanding any time soon, but yeah, I think I do
认为我们遵循一套规则，而且我们本质上是被编程的。我不会把灵魂和其他没有灵魂的实体区分开来。所以对我来说，说“是的，可能都一样”要容易得多。但我能理解其他人会觉得这种区分很困难。
think that we fall a set of rules and that we're essentially programmed. I don't distinguish between souls and other entities without souls. And so it's much easier for me to say, yeah, it's probably all the same. But I can see that other people would find that distinction difficult.
你曾经谈论过这个吗？你曾经和别人探讨过这个吗，比如，你对你丈夫说过吗？我非常喜欢你，但我认为你是一台我很喜欢它的、非常聪明的机器。我没有明确地对他这样说过，但是……当你从这次旅行中回家时。是的，我们到时候看情况。
Do you ever talk about this? Do you ever run this by other people instead of say, do you tell your husband, for example? I like you very much, but I think you're a really intelligent machine that I love doing it. I haven't explicitly said that to him, but... When you go home, from this trip. Yeah, we'll see how that goes.
凯特·达林是麻省理工学院媒体实验室的研究专家。我们今天的对话是在杰罗姆酒店（Hotel Jerome）面对现场观众录制的。非常感谢。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、雷内克·劳尔（Renek Lauer）和帕尔斯·沙阿（Parth Shah）制作。我们的团队包括贾尼斯·梅特（Janish Met）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Penman）。NPR负责节目的副总裁是阿尼亚·格伦曼（Anya Grunman）。
Kid Darling is a research specialist at the MIT Media Lab. Our conversation today was taped before a live audience at the hotel Jerome and asked Thank you so much. This week's show was produced by Raina Cohen, Tara Boyle, Renek Lauer and Parth Shah. Our team includes two teams, one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, and one team, Raina Cohen, Tara Boyle, Renek Larr and Parts Cha. Our team includes Janish Met and Maggie Penman. NPR's Vice President for Programming is Anya Grunman.
你可以在我们的Instagram页面上找到萨曼莎（Samantha）的照片和视频，她是我们的克利奥恐龙。我们也在Facebook和Twitter上。如果你喜欢本周的节目，请在社交媒体上与朋友分享这一集。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，下周见。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can find photos and a video of Samantha, our Pio Dinosaur on our Instagram page. We're also on Facebook and Twitter. If you enjoyed this week's show, please share the episode with friends on social media. I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的Instagram页面上找到萨曼莎（我们的Pio恐龙）的照片和视频。我们也在Facebook和Twitter上。如果你喜欢本周的节目，请在社交媒体上与朋友分享这一集。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，下周见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。